elle est l'auteur du livre d'après
défaite qui fait des remous à l'ump
roselyne bachelot bonsoir à feu et à
sang donc bigre que la campagne
présidentielle a été dur à vivre de
l'intérieur pour vous d'où ce journal
qui était votre refuge en même temps
écrivez-vous un l'ump cherche ses
valeurs à travers un droit d'inventaire
vous dirai dans un instant à corinne
delpech de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire quels sont les vôtres et
pourquoi vous ne les avez pas retrouvé
dans le sarkozy de 1 2012 ne fut en rien
ressemblant à 2007 pour vous un autre
refuge pour vous c'est la solidarité
féminine 1 roselyne bachelot et le
combat partagé des femmes ce qui
n'empêche pas d'ailleurs pour vous
d'avoir une réputation de flingueuse
comme dit votre amie christine boutin
dans le portrait que vous a consacré ses
fringues & cie et puis donc perrine
tarneaud vous interrogera sur ces
différents points tout à l'heure et puis
je signale aux téléspectateurs qu'ils
peuvent intervenir et poser directement
leurs questions à vous même par le biais
de l'application tivi tchèque de notre
partenaire orange
alors d'abord il ya un nouveau président
à l'assemblée nationale a lancé mme
bachelot vous avez décidé de vous
présenter aux élections de ne plus être
député c'est donc claude bartolone et
ben oui ça fait comme le dit madame
guigou ça fait le sixième homme pour les
plus grands postes de l'état présidents
premiers ministres présidents des
chambres présidents des groupes
parlementaires
c'est trop inutile de vous dire que je
n'ai pas été appelé même si j'avais été
député a voté pour claude bartolone
mais toutefois si j'avais eu à voter à
choisir à l'intérieur du groupe
socialiste j'aurais évidemment par
solidarité féminine voté pour elisabeth
guigou pour laquelle j'ai une très
grande considération estime je me
souviens de son beau combat pour la lois
paritaires et nous sommes retrouvés sur
beaucoup de sujets at rendu hommage
mutuellement d'ailleurs
là ceci étant je partage avec claude
bartolone à qui j'ai envoyé un petit
message de sympathie
l'amour du football of pas dans
n'importe quel football et j'ai mouillé
je veux faire cette façon dit bouge pas
celui des petits caïds
voilà des bleus sur terre mais je vais
vous aviez qualifié comme ça mais sur le
trop plein d'hommes au sommet de l'état
on n'a rien à dire c'est vrai et je dois
dire que je vais pas critiquer les uns
et les autres parce que évidemment dans
ma famille politique on est plutôt
invité à balayer devant notre porte
hier puisque les élections internes avec
des hommes qui sont de qualité
d'ailleurs qui sont tous des amis sur
lequel un parent je n'ai rien à dire au
contraire parce que je les aime
tendrement mais l'ensemble fait quand
même quelque chose de très masculin on
avance en quantité on avance sans doute
mois sur le domaine qualitatif
oui alors là encore parlé d'une femme
qui a un qui n'est pas de votre bord
cécile duflot qui a donc accédé à la
fonction de ministre avec liquide depuis
bien sûr est obligé de composer composé
dans le langage vous savez ça vous
connaissez on en parlera tout à l'heure
vous avez vécu certaines servitude au
gouvernement c'est même le thème de
voeux de votre ouvrage de roselyne
bachelot
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'attitude
de la ministre
cécile duflot qui a qui admet finalement
que sa collègue madame briquettes été
chassés du ministère de l'écologie dans
la serre des forages au large de la
guyane alors cécile duflot découvre les
servitudes de la fonction ministérielle
qui explique d'ailleurs les dire en
creux certaines démarches de mon lit
vous vous souvenez de la fameuse phrase
de de jean pierre chevènement un
ministre ça par où ça ferme sa gueule
excusez la trivialité de l'expression et
puis j'ai une pensée pour nicole bricq
que je connais bien depuis plusieurs
années et franchement de voir son visage
ravagé quittant le conseil des ministres
véritablement la première victime de
françois hollande au président de la
république et jean marc ayrault premier
ministre la première victime de leur
dureté peut-être des obligations
extérieur ça a été une femme est une
femme de qualité
je lui envoie mais mes cordiales penser
oui mais pas apprécié en fait son
ministère de l'écologie vérifier cela ne
changera pas du tout apprécié parce que
à l'évidence passé de l'écologie qui est
un des premiers ministères de la
république au ministère du commerce
extérieur certes important mais dont on
connaît les limites de l'action le faire
de cette façon aussi brutale et sur des
attendus qui sont des attendus
extrêmement contestable c'est évidemment
très dur pour elle je n'imagine alors
vous avez des mots très doux pour
certaines femmes politiques pas tout
on en parlera tout à l'heure pour les
appeler mais petite chérie dans votre
livre celle qui était sous votre tutelle
notamment mesdames greffe et mon champ
mais marie-anne montchamp dénonce de son
côté aujourd'hui dans les colonnes du
figaro votre dynamitage de votre famille
politique vous l'avez lu alors qu'est ce
que vous répondez à votre petite chérie
je réponds qu'à n'a sans doute pas lu
mon livre parce qu'elle verrait que le
livre est un hommage appuyé à l'action
du président de la république nicolas
sarkozy et que je rends hommage à son
bilan de façon continue dans le livre je
connais marianne je connais sa démarche
qui est une démarche humaniste je sais
que nous partageons les mêmes valeurs
son combat pour les personnes
handicapées a montré à quel point elle
était sur ses démarches
ces démarches sociales elle avait
d'ailleurs au début du mandat
violemment critiqué nicolas sarkozy
quand elle défend des dominique de
villepin les remarques que je fais sur
nicolas sarkozy apparaissent comme à
l'eau de rose
à côté des critiques qu'elle même a fait
et donc elle devrait peut-être balayer
devant sa porte
je lui envoie mais amicale pensé à lui
avait dit que votre livre c'est un air
d'opérette on connaît votre goût pour
l'art lyrique
une petite musique de soutien en fait à
françois fillon ce lac est à l'oeuvre
dans votre livre
non c'est pas la ligne directrice du
livre le livre il a voulu être dans une
période agitée à témoignages pour
l'histoire
je revendique sa subjectivité je
revendique son instantanéité on va en
parler mais je revendique aussi le fait
qu'on ne soit pas d'accord avec moi
vous revendiquez votre amitié votre foi
que sais je rebondis dans le maquis et
ma proximité avec françoise km est le
meilleur pour faire gagner l'ump en 2017
alors moi je différencie les deux les
deux échéances
pour moi les deux échéances ne sont pas
liés je pense que notre famille doit se
reconstruire
reconstruire sa base idéologique ces
méthodes de fonctionnement les hommes et
les femmes qui vont être aux commandes
françois fillon me paraît le mieux
outillé le plus apte à faire cette
reconstruction
je n'ai aucune antipathie antinomie
envers jean françois copé qui a été un
très bon secrétaire général
je pense que nous passons à une autre
période ce sont des élections internes
nous allons nous y employer d'accord
ensuite alors 2017 ensuite tout cas
laissé entendre les peu en paix les on
peut vous n'aurez pas être en retrait
par exemple sur valérie pécresse qui dit
oui ce sera lui le meilleur pour nous
faire gagner
vous qui êtes encore plus proche de lui
alors moi ce que je dis j'ai tendance à
penser cela bien sûr dé cacher derrière
mon petit doigt
mais je pense qu'il faudra que ce soit
validé par une démarche très différente
le président de l'ump n'a pas à être
vocation n'a pas vocation à être le
candidat de droit divin à l'élection
présidentielle il faudra qu'ils
conquièrent non seulement notre base
militante mais une base beaucoup plus
large c'est la raison pour laquelle je
milite pour des primaires ouvertes
d'accord mais alors ça les malheurs
c'est très mal à françois fillon est
l'homme du rassemblement et qualité qui
fera un excellent président de de l'ump
feront très probablement qu'il fera un
excellent candidat à la présidentielle
de 2010
mais voyez où on élire le président
prendra bien de procéder à cette
élection je pourrais voter pour monsieur
lent on vient de procéder à cette
élection
je trouve qu'il est encore un peu tôt la
fesci sont les les obstacles les uns
après les autres
d'accord françois fillon alors
évidemment il a toutes les qualités d'un
quand on vous lit vous avez une grande
proximité avec lui vous aviez également
les qualités il a beaucoup hélas
beaucoup de qualités vous êtes retrouvé
souvent à débattre on est de la même
politique même origine du gaullisme
social
on est nous sommes des gaullistes nous
sommes effectivement proximité
territoriale nous sommes oui nous avons
beaucoup travaillé ensemble et ça fait
nous sommes des amis de trente ans voilà
alors il n'y a pas de vous qui créez des
livres sur sur le quinquennat il ya
votre ancien collègue marc-philippe
daubresse qui a écrit à un quinquennat
s'investit tranquille alors lui il n'y
pas la même chose que vous vous déplacez
françois fillon est dit il nous rappelle
me nous ramène à l'époque de la reine
margot or il parle du poison et qui sait
manier le poison
il a un grand pouvoir de nuisance quand
il se sait menacé
françois fillon il suffit de voir
comment il a réussi à faire barrage à
jean-louis borloo qui guignait matignon
je laisse le témoignage marc philippe
daubresse
moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié marc philippe
quand il s'est occupé d'un travail
excellent sur le revenu solidarité
active dont j'ai d'ailleurs largement
repris des attendus
il a dans son action ministérielle était
un homme de qualité
maintenant il a peut-être tel ou tel il
va donc devoir en sueur il a d'autres
préférant d'abord moi je vis mon
mon expérience d'autres regardent cela
d'un entrepôt alors j'ai encore encore
une réaction c'est valérie rosso debord
qui sur publicsenat.fr ne trouve pas
très bien ce livre que vous avez signé
vous ai dit c'est pas très bien de faire
de l'argent sur le dos de nicolas
sarkozy voilà ces propos qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez vous là aussi valérie
faux pas il faut pas se lancer dans des
attaques qui sont des attaques basses
qui sont des attaques sur la personne
que l'on dise que mon livre on n'est pas
d'accord avec ce qui est dedans très
bien c'est le débat qu'ont encore dans
l'entente qu'on en compte est ce que je
remarque c'est que personne ne conteste
les faits il ya même ça alors là je dois
dire je n'ai trouvé personne pour
contester le fond du livre il ya même un
certain nombre de gens qui comptent qui
s'expriment traitants et qui disent que
j'en ai pas de nom mais que j'en ai pas
dire c'est comme avaient eux mêmes écrit
livre il aurait peut-être été plus
sévère il y en a qui dit certains disent
ils étaient trop tôt oui voilà c'est un
débat moi je n'ai pas cette cet avis là
je souhaiterais que sur un livre qui est
un livre sincère on est un commentaire
qui ne serait pas une attaque
personnelle d'accord alors il ya ce ne
sont pas des attaques personnelles mais
il ya un trio qui revient tout au long
des pages c'est la beta 3 tête un tel
cumul qualifiés c'est-à-dire patrick
buisson emmanuelle mignon et claude
guéant
est ce que vous diriez comme nathalie
kosciusko morizet que vous avez beaucoup
vous défendez dans ce livre que
l'afrique puisse alors pas besoin d'être
défendus date a été attaquée qualité
voilà est ce que vous diriez que patrick
buisson voulait faire gagner charles
maurras alors de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy dans ce cas de figure de
l'extrême droite catholique et puis le
soutien je suis je me suis sans mot race
par beaucoup à nous à nos concitoyens à
nos compatriotes à l'heure actuelle
nathalie a fait une référence historique
et et et littéraire dans une très grande
une très grande force et d'une très
grande violence
oui on peut considérer que
monsieur buisson fait partie d'une d'une
droite très très marquée sur le plan
idéologique d'ailleurs il s'en ils s'en
réclament de façon de façon claire ce
qu'il a voulu faire gagner charles
maurras je crois qu'avec beaucoup de
sincérité il a voulu faire gagner
nicolas sarkozy il n'y est pas arrivé à
bien alors vous n'étiez pas ce mardi à
la première rencontre de l'ump sur ses
valeurs justement on va en parler d'un
instant avec et corinne delpech pourquoi
j'avais d'autres j'avais d'autres
engagements dont je participerai euro
participeraient ce débat s'est fait
confiance à jean françois copé pour
rédiger la nouvelle charte des valeurs
de l'ump écoutez moi a priori je fais
confiance aux gens c'est aux fruits
qu'on juge annaba je veux que toutes les
les options soit entendue dans l'ump et
je souhaite me jette la fatwa sur aucune
démarche
jusque là ça s'est bien passé puisque
quand j'avais dit avant les élections
que je n'approuvais pas la théorie du ni
ni
je les dis calmement devant le bureau
politique en euros et en république un
jeu des formes vous le front républicain
je dois dire je n'ai été l'objet d'
aucun ostracisme de la page
c'est la conférence moi je déteste les
procès d'intention alors on va voir
quelles sont donc ces interrogations de
l'ump sur ces valeurs avec fabrice culé
et on en parle plus avant avec ma
famille corrie dans un instant fabrice
sans la droitisation votre avis nicolas
sarkozy aurait pu gagner
faut-il comme certains le réclament
procéder à un inventaire mme une sorte
de droit d'inventaire il peut y avoir un
inventaire ou un examen de conscience
le droit d'inventaire c'est l'expression
à la mode à l'ump lancées par plusieurs
anciens ministres la demande dérange
divise au sein du parti
chacun réagit en fonction de son
tempérament et de sa personnalité mais
je pense que si on est mal à l'aise au
gouvernement au moment où des décisions
sont prises on n'est pas obligé d'y
rester
car ouvrir ce droit d'inventaire c'est
d'abord instruire leur propre procès
d'où un certain malaise
chantal jouanno est l'une des rares à
s'être démarqué pendant la campagne
aujourd'hui elle appelle elle aussi à
une autocritique oui pour vraiment une
analyse approfondie oui pour une
réflexion complète sur nos valeurs pour
éviter de nouveaux dérapages ou le
sentiment qu'il puisse y avoir la
moindre porosité entre nous et l'extrême
droite après prud'hon sur le terme de
droit d'inventaire le risque pour l'ump
voire deux courants s'affrontent et la
droite populaire face à la droite plus
humaniste la question anime ces
parlementaires a même si le président du
groupe au sénat veut couper court au
débat
nous devons concentrer nos efforts sur
les attaques contre le gouvernement
actuel les abus et les changements de
position avec lavabo taubira et les
annonces qui sont faites moins là pas de
devoir d'inventaire surtout pas pour les
ministres qui ont profité de cette
situation longtemps au droit
d'inventaire jean françois copé préfère
un groupe de travail lancé ce matin sur
les valeurs et la ligne politique du
parti
ce que j'ai proposé ce cirque mes
convictions mais pas seulement on sait
je crois des éléments qui sont de nature
à rassembler notre famille est
bien sûr tout ça va être étayé
développer amende et voilà maintenant
après deux claques électorales jean
françois copé veut à tout prix éviter le
clash et s'afficher comme rassembleur à
cinq mois du congrès du parti et ce
matin chacun était appelé je cite à
apporter leur part de vérité mais à
l'ump
toutes les vérités ne sont pas bonnes à
dire voilà corinne delpech est avec nous
vos bons soir corinne vos questions donc
madame bachelot dans votre livre vous
montrer de façon très claire un certain
épuisement de votre partie de son projet
de ces hommes et d'enfants une bonne
cure d'opposition c'est pas quelque
chose qui permettra de connaître
peut-être ce que je note c'est que l'ump
a toujours été dans dans le gouvernement
elle est fondée en 2000 à l'ump
et peut-être que la participation
gouvernement la participation au pouvoir
nous a servi de base de contrebande
idéologique et c'est normal parce que
quand on est au pouvoir
eh bien on défend des projets sectoriels
on se bat pour les crédits pour la
famille pour la santé enfin pour les
sujets qui n'ont tenu particulièrement à
coeur et que j'ai eu en responsabilité
et puis nous avons essuyé une série de
revers électoraux qui ont commencé
d'ailleurs en 2005 avec la perte du
référendum vous savez moi je fais un
jaffe je fais un paquet global je
commence pas en 2007 je commence en 2002
perte du référendum perd des élections
municipales des élections cantonales des
élections régionales des élections
présidentielles des élections
législatives tout ça fait un paquet qui
nous oblige à nous interroger
et contrairement ce que disent les uns
et les autres
moi je n'attaque pas le bilan nicolas
sarkozy dans mon livre à je le redis je
le défends je le défend avec force
c'est un grand président de la
république nicolas sarkozy
certains font mine de dire que j'attaque
le bilan du président
mais certainement pas et c'est
parfaitement clair les cas le bilan de
campagne
je pars d'un autre d'une autre chose je
parle d'un choix stratégique dans la
campagne à vous poser une question est
ce qu une cure d'opposition est utile ça
peut avoir du bon effectivement il faut
savoir que la dernière élection fallait
un président socialiste et 1995
cette élection c'est vrai elle était
grosse si je puis dire d'une volonté
d'alternance 2002
il faut dire jacques chirac est au 2e
tour face à jean marie le pen
82% des voix 2007 monsieur hollande
avait décidé de l'échec de madame royal
il a été le principal allié de monsieur
sarkozy monsieur hollande on nous on ne
nous fera pas le parti socialiste ne
nous a pas fait deux fois ce même cadeau
bien entendu le parti socialiste avait
décidé de la défaite de madame royal
d'abord très affirmative effectivement
là au micro et dans votre livre journée
pour témoignage un certain nombre de
deux militants du parti socialiste au
plus haut niveau
vous vous dites que ce parti a été fait
pour le gouvernement a toujours
gouvernés qu'est ce qui vous y retient
dans le fond dans l'échec est ce que
vous n'êtes pas du tout tenté par ce
qu'entreprend de reconstruire jean louis
borloo même si dans votre livre vous le
traitez de pseudo alliez vous le portez
dans notre cas j'aime bien jean louis
borloo jeudi qu'il nous apporte un coup
de poignard très très très toxique un
certain niveau un certain moment quand
il a poussé ses pions pour devenir
premier ministre et roulant virage
social et à ce moment là effectivement
il avait l'air de dire en creux que nous
ne mettions pas une politique sociale or
la caractéristique de nicolas sarkozy
c'est d'avoir avec beaucoup de
volontarisme préserver le modèle social
dans ce pays
certains reprochent même nos dépenses
sociales puisque les dépenses sociales
n'ont cessé d'augmenter pendant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy et moi
j'ai été tout à fait à la manoeuvre pour
défendre ce modèle alors maintenant les
je crois que le il a décidé d'avoir une
d'être à la tête d'un groupe politique
du centre pas seulement pas
non ce ma famille n'est pas la famille
centriste 1 je suis un gaulliste une
gaulliste social mais il est certain que
sur un certain nombre de valeurs
centristes que j'ai redéfini à
nombreuses reprises j'ai vu d'ailleurs
que le corpus idéologique que j'avais
défini été repris par jean louis borloo
dans ses déclarations c'est à dire oui
les valeurs de la démocratie chrétienne
oui les valeurs de l'atlantisme oui les
valeurs du fédéralisme européen joints
et pas le contraire
et oui les valeurs de delà de la
décentralisation je n'avais pas entendu
jusque là définir ce corpus idéologique
de façon aussi claire et cdc des
chaussures lequel on peut discuter
tellement je suis un département où la
famille centriste est très présent j'ai
l'habitude de travailler avec eux et
toujours de façon très constructive
est ce que l'ump n'est pas dans une
tentative de syncrétisme qui à l'heure
des crises ne sera plus de mise elle se
montrera jamais assez social pour la
gauche
jamais assez sécuritaire pour l'extrême
droite elle est dans une sorte d'entre
deux où est sa place
l'ump pour moi ensuite le débat se fera
puisqu'il n'a jamais eu lieu
c'est une famille de centre droit
c'est une famille c'est à grand parti
conservateur éclairé qui se définit sur
des valeurs qui sont des valeurs
européennes de renforcement de la
politique européenne qui se définit
comme pensant que seule l'économie de
marché peut créer de la richesse mais
que cette économie de marché doit être
régulée par de puissantes par de
puissants politique sociale et c'est un
mouvement politique qui veut faire le
syncrétisme entre un jacobinisme qui
assure l'égalité des citoyens mais une
puissante des concentrations de l'état
mission impossible
noront non on nous l'avons nous l'avons
réussie où les gaullistes à deux noms à
de nombreuses reprises biens volés dans
les camps même qu'il ya des
personnalités de l'ump qui reprennent le
discours du front national qu'est ce que
vous en faites de ces gens là qui n'ont
pas leur place
alors tout dépend ce que vous entendez
par reprendre le 10 à voter front
national
je donne clairement que toute alliance
ou dialogues explicite ou implicite avec
le front national n'est pas recevable
pour moi j'ai d'ailleurs dit ya fort
longtemps et je leur dis à chaque fois
qu'on a touché au principe si le
heureusement ma famille ne l'a jamais
fait ni françois copé ni françois fillon
ni nicolas sarkozy non plaidé pour une
alliance ou un dialogue avec le front
national
j'ai dit que je quitterais immédiatement
ma famille politique si cela devait
arriver donc les choses sont claires et
d'ailleurs cette cette vision est
partagée par je pense la totalité des
chefs politiques de l'uem a forcément
c'est ton direct c'est comme ça que je
fais je suis bien dans ma famille
politique
oui mais voyez vous on n'a peut-être pas
c'est parler du fond et de dire pourquoi
donc valeurs étaient opposées à celles
du front national
et je remarque quand on en parle
et enfin on en parle et bien les
électeurs qu'ils pouvaient être tentés
par cette alliance tout d'un coup
réalisé et on voit de façon continue les
électeurs changer d'avis les électeurs
qui sont nos électeurs de l'opposition
maintenant j'allais dire de la majorité
mais de l'opposition sur les valeurs à
nouveau donc jean france a coupé a
commencé ce chantier est il le place
sous le signe de trois mots générosité
courage fermeté est ce que c'est votre
devise pour l'ump aussi comment ne pas
être d'accord avec des termes aussi
généraux et généreux ça c'est votre jeu
mais l'entité générosité courage fermeté
sont des valeurs qui se croivent dont
vous demandez à n'importe quel homme
femme politique de droite ou de gauche
il se reconnaît dans ces trois mots je
crois qu'il ne dira oui alors maintenant
il faudra voir s'il faudra soit il
faudra voir le contenu qu'on donnera à
tout cela et on l'a on va avancer le
travail commence je redis que je ne fais
pas de procès d'intention aux uns et aux
autres alors un thème sur lequel ce
contenu peut s'exercer c'est
l'immigration que doit dire l'ump sur ce
dossier sarkozy voulait
le président sarkozy le candidat sarkozy
voulait diminuer par deux l'immigration
je dois je respire de l'autre parent qui
se veut dire de façon forte que
l'immigration est une chance pour notre
pays mais que cette immigration doit
être régulée l'immigration c'est quelque
chose qui se fait en fonction des
capacités d'accueil de notre pays de ses
capacités d'accueil et de ses besoins
non et que il n'ya pas quand tout d'un
coup on régule l'arrivée des delà du
flux migratoires il n'y a pas une
politique d'exclusion soit pas de
politique de stigmatisation faut pouvoir
accueillir les 1 les uns et les autres
il faut faire très attention au discours
que l'on tient parce que moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé dans les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives à suivre
c'est que véritablement il ya eu des
décès des banlieues des secteurs où les
populations d'origine française
d'origine immigrée était très fort et on
voit des scores pour monsieur hollande à
85 ou 90%
il n'y a aucune raison que ces
populations ces personnes d'origine
immigrée ne se retrouve pas dans les
valeurs de l'ump
c'est donc on a leur a envoyé un message
négatif et ça il faut y réfléchir ce
sont des français ils sont des citoyens
français sur le sur le social maintenant
la frugalité arrive elle est sans doute
inévitable
comment réinventer des solidarités à
l'heure où les corps dans la bourse vont
se resserrer c'est sans doute le sujet
le plus important et nous devons avancer
dans trois directions
la première direction c'est de réfléchir
au financement de la protection sociale
la protection sociale est
majoritairement assise sur le travail
ça ruine la compétitivité de notre pays
et je ne peux que regretter que monsieur
hollande et reculer sur le sujet de la
restructuration du financement de la
protection sociale
le deuxième élément c'est l'efficience
il y a des marges d'efficience dans la
protection sociale tout à fait
considérable on pas on parle de la
dépendance
savez vous que la mauvaise organisation
de notre système c'est 2 me
yar d'euros par an d'hospitalisation
inutile deuxième élément l'efficience
troisième élément la protection de notre
modèle social c'est à dire de réfléchir
à sa protection aux frontières de
l'europe et à son harmonisation à
l'intérieur de l'europe dans ce domaine
dans ces deux domaines l'efficience je
ne peux que regretter la position de
monsieur lent qui veut du toujours plus
et dans la protection de à l'intérieur
de l'europe
le refroidissement de l'axé franco
allemand car rien ne peut se faire dans
ce domaine de l'harmonisation dans un
dans un processus de glaciation voulue
par monsieur nantes dernière question
corinne présentant un programme l'on se
demande ce que veut faire passer mme
bachelot demain un plus être député
mais toujours est très active en
politique toujours être très active en
politique louis il a su je suis une
citoyenne
j'ai le sentiment qu'on ne participe pas
seulement au débat politique en mettant
des biens le sénateur même si je suis
ici dans dans le lieu du parlement une
question attentif sur une figure que que
dont vous parlez dans votre livre qui
est valérie trierweiler qui est en jeu
vincom vous et pour le que vous montrer
une certaine sympathie en tout cas pas
d'antipathie comment jugez vous ses
premiers pas de pros madame écoutez je
suis très jeune et je ne parle pas de
façon intime de la compagne du président
de la république j'ai eu des demandes de
parce que j'étais angevine juin de sa
demande d'interview pour en parler je me
suis toujours refusé
je pense qu'effectivement elle à elle a
commis un impair qui a beaucoup nui et
qui mise beaucoup à son compagnon je
pense qu'elle ne le souhaitait pas voilà
tout le monde peut faire tout le monde
peut faire une erreur
est elle restée journalistes à vos yeux
alors moi je pense que oui alors je suis
profondément révoltés par ce le fait que
les femmes poli des femmes d'hommes
politiques devraient renoncer à leur
métier peut-être l'exercer d'une autre
façon ils trouvaient ça y est un chef de
cabinet à l'elysée serait pas bien
fréquents non oui mais enfin elle est
l'épousé du président de la république
l'accompagnent maintenant tout ça n'a
plus beaux l'aide les différences n'ont
plus beaucoup de sens
toutes les épouses du président de la
république on lui un cabinet on sait
très bien qu'elles sont la journaliste
indépendante et journaliste certes mais
nous avons sont aussi dans la société
shenzhen
il y avait il y avait des femmes de
président d'honneur m'aiguiller pour le
moins y avait des femmes de présidents
de la république y avait des femmes de
préfets y avait des femmes
d'ambassadeurs qui n'avait pas de réseau
il n'avait pas de d'activité
professionnelle les temps changent il va
falloir vous y habituer presse est
préparée quand j'y compte avril dans
tous les cas je disais tout à l'heure au
filmage clos les droits des femmes donc
et même de la première compagne et la
solidarité féminine dans l'action
politique occupe une grande place dans
votre livre méthane traduit quand même à
constater donc votre réputation de l'un
d'eux s'était fait aussi au détriment de
quelques unes j'aime bien martine aubry
elle a vraiment choisi une mission
impossible
je lui souhaite de tout coeur qu'elle se
casse la gueule quoi à elle a de
l'humour est allé direct roselyne
bachelot direct en interview mais aussi
dans son livre qui fait le régal des
amateurs de règlements de comptes dans à
feu et à sang
l'ancien ministre révèle ouvertement son
animosité pour certaines anciennes
collègues comme rachida dati qualifiée
d' erreur de casting
l'ex garde des sceaux n'a pas apprécié
au répondre madame bachelot avait
brouillé
d'ailleurs les médecins je vous demande
de pose la question médecin
nicolas sarkozy avait souhaité la sortir
du gouvernement en ce moment là elle a
supplié françois fillon pourrait rester
je trouve c'est pas très joli ce livre
contre le président qui l'a nommé du
fait du prince mais dans son inventaire
roselyne bachelot décerne aussi quelques
bons points
parmi ces chouchoute ses anciennes
secrétaires d'état marie-anne montchamp
et claude greff mais aussi christine
lagarde ou encore valérie létard qui le
lui rend bien
rose est une est quelqu'un qui est
profondément intéressé passionnés
attachée par ses sujets elle va au fond
au fond des choses
et lorsqu'elle se trouve à ses côtés
avec des biens d'aider d'autres
collègues qui sont dans la même réalité
dans la même logique ça se passe
forcément bien il faut dire que valérie
létard a su se montrer disciplinés au
gouvernement contrairement à rama yade
dont la mésentente avec roselyne
bachelot était de notoriété publique
mais le poste de secrétaire d'état n'est
pas forcément facile lorsque avec le
ministre que qui est votre ministre de
référence et bien les choses ne sont pas
toujours évidentes ou lorsque vous ne
partagez pas toujours la même vision ou
la même personnalité la même façon de
voir l'action politique c'est pas tous
les jours simple et oui les ministres
d'un même gouvernement ne s'entendent
pas toujours et la solidarité féminine
peut virer à la guerre ouverte
quand on confronte quelques caractères
bien trempés voilà nous a rejoints pour
vous interroger
d'abord je n'attaque pas je dis
simplement qu'il est très difficile pour
des personnes qui n'ont aucune
expérience de la vie parlementaire et de
la vie politique d'être ministre d'un
seul coup je crois que d'un nicolas
sarkozy a reconnu qu'il avait fait une
erreur dans la nomination de rachida
dati et de rama yade et qu'il les avait
en quelque sorte gâchée parce que quand
on ne connaît pas les codes de la vie
parlementaire en particulier on se livre
à certaines errances dans sa démarche
et si elles ont été des ministres
détesté dans le groupe parlementaire ump
ça leur a nui parce que voilà ça a été
ressentie de l'extérieur des mauvais
choix une erreur de casting
voilà mais se sont essayés jeudi dans
mon liés ce sont des femmes de qualité
bien sûr je veux bien sûr qu'on est
nommé par le fait du prince je sais pas
si nicolas sarkozy est un pas rachida
dati a été aussi nommé du fait du prince
voilà
et j'étais une vraie personnalité
politique j'ai existait depuis 30 ans
dans la vie politique j'étais ministre
avant d'être le ministre
j'ai été ministre avant d'être là
ministre de nicolas sarkozy ces
dénominations qui s'est un peu imposé
aujourd'hui en raison de la parité on
voit dans la composition du gouvernement
actuel qui se veut strictement paritaire
est ce qu'il ya le même risque pour des
jeunes femmes qui sont rentrés dans le
gouvernement de jean marc ayrault
moi je connais à peu près toutes les
femmes du gouvernement hérault où il ya
des femmes qui ont certes pas
d'expérience ministérielle mais qui ont
une expérience une expérience politique
et parlementaire tout à fait conséquente
soit comme chef de parti comme madame
duflot soit comme comme parlementaire
nous verrons bien
nous verrons bien en tout cas voilà ce
qu'est ce que ça apporterait pas de
jugement a priori sur tel ou tel mais
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire à toutes ces nouvelles femmes
fraîchement ministre est-ce qu'ils
avaient une recommandation oui que les
batailles ne sont pas gagnés que les
batailles de l'égalité de la parité ne
sont pas gagnés derrière les affichages
des manoeuvres de minoration de leurs de
leurs actions
des manoeuvres de dévalorisation qui ne
viendront pas d'ailleurs uniquement de
leurs collègues du gouvernement
mais largement de l'administration des
groupes parlementaires des corps
intermédiaires la parole des femmes est
systématiquement dévalorisé il faudra
qu'elles se tiennent bon et surtout
qu'entre femmes elles essaient de
d'avoir le maximum de solidarité j'ai
aussi reproché à certaines de mes
collègues pas rachida dati parce que
j'ai pas eu de j'ai eu des sujets avec
lesquels nous nous sommes bien entendu
mais avec rama yade moi c'est pas des
histoires de femmes comme on dit
de façon un peu comment dirais-je
condescendante c'est que finalement sur
des sujets elle s'est opposée à moi
alors que les arbitrages étaient rendus
temps d'assumer appellation des raisons
d'insubordination bien sûr roselyne
bachelot ce que j'ai eu un petit
pincement au coeur aujourd'hui en cette
rentrée parlementaire vous avez été
pendant 25 ans député je suis très
surprise parce que évidemment quand on
dit non on a tendance à dire oui tout ça
chin ap on essaie de faire la pierre
c'est vrai c'est vrai je n'ai pas eu de
pincement au coeur
d'abord parce que cette maison c'est une
maison citoyenne elle est finalement la
propriété des députés mais aussi de tous
ceux qui les ont élus
c'est le temple de la démocratie on
meurt sur les barricades pour avoir des
députés on meurt pas sur les barricades
pour avoir des mères ou des conseillers
généraux
c'est ça la démocratie je gens portent
comme un trésor l'émotion qui m'a saisi
quand j'ai pénétré pour la première fois
comme parlementaire dans l'hémicycle
je me suis dit mon être meilleurs aussi
maine-et-loire j'ai cette chance
extraordinaire
mon meilleur souvenir c'est à l'évidence
ce discours du pacs parce que là c'était
un moment d'émotion violent et certains
députés de l'opposition et de la
majorité m'ont dit à ce moment là on ne
savait pas pourquoi on est et on était
là et grâce à vous on l'a compris en
tout cas c'est un discours qui est
fondateur dans votre carrière politique
est en tout cas fait comme j'ai eu le
grand bonheur je le raconte souvent mais
sur un quai de métro de voir un homme
s'approcher de moi et réciter par coeur
plusieurs années après le discours que
j'avais prononcé
je ne sais pas s'il ya dans l'hémicycle
du sénat ou de l'assemblée nationale un
seul parlementaire qui peut dire qu'un
jour à citoyen lui a dit parker un
discours qu'il a prononcé j'ai eu cette
chance extraordinaire d'avoir entendu
cela mais ça n'est plus vous qui
mènerait le combat pour le mariage
homosexuel
non au muscle mettre à ma place de
citoyenne bien sûr un peu l'écart votre
bureau de l'assemblée nationale vous
avez suivi les conseils de votre père de
ne pas personnaliser
lazano personnel pas une faute c'était
le cas également dans tous vos postes
ministériels oui bien sûr il faut
pouvoir partir
il faut être un voyageur sans bagage
personnel mon père à plessala cesse de
l'adieu il faut quitter les choses oui
avant qu'elles ne vous quitte c'est ce
que j'ai voulu faire tout au long de ma
vie politique mais je la continue par
d'autres moyens
27 % de femmes aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale contre 5 7% quand j'ai avancé
et oui on est et on était une espèce
rare maintenant je me sens même si on
n'est pas à la parité bien entendu et
j'ai fait de mon mieux demain pas un
tollé on atteint la masse critique qu'on
situe à peu près entre 25 et 30 %
c'est-à-dire où vraiment le socle est là
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
durcir les sanctions
certains ont proposé rachida dati mais
aussi l'actuel ministre l'actuelle
ministre en charge des droits des femmes
a à proposer qu'il n'y ait plus aucun
financement politique publique pour les
partis qui ne respecteraient pas la
parité
je trouve que c'est une excellente
démarche et j'y souscris totalement même
si vous connaissez ma théorie
moi je suis pour la division par deux
des circonscriptions et pour l'élection
d'un ticket hommes femmes qui assurerait
la parité parfaite est composé de votre
livre que décolla sarkozy vous a négligé
comme ministre comme ministre pham l'été
je dois dire non il n'a pas négligé
comme ministre dans mon action
ministérielle où j'ai toujours là l'an
passé là nicolas sarkozy et j'ai très
bien travaillé avec lui non c'est dans
la campagne électorale
oui où il a écouté d'autres conseillers
et je n'ai pas été l'objet d'une ve
d'acord excuses
spécifiques avaient dressé mûri il nous
a descendu non pas encore mais n'a reçu
il ya deux trois jours le livre lui et
dédicaces vous dites que vous avez dû
faire profil bas rhin
durant la campagne elle avoue fait
mentir votre réputation et mme bachelot
c'est à dire que quand un champion et
dans la et la sauce dans la course ou
sur le terrain c'est plus le moment de
lui dire tiens fait si vous fait ça
d'accord alors justement on parle de
terrain l'équipe de france de foot vous
n'aviez pas mâcher vos mots après le
mondial 2010 parlant de caïds immatures
en parlant des joueurs de foot est ce
que finalement rien n'a changé
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que seul
et les phrases que j'avais prononcé qui
ont parfois été considéré comme un peu
murs se trouve à se trouve sans doute ou
moins en partie vérifier c'est désolant
c'est désolant d'abord parce que faut
dire que dans ce dernier match on a
vraiment l'équipe de france a vraiment
mal joué on peut perdre en jouant pas
trop mal ou en ayant des lueurs on
attaque ou en défense a vraiment
l'électroencéphalogramme était plat mais
là je dirais que d'une certaine façon
laurent blanc tenu son pari qui était
d'amener l'équipe en quarts de finale
la reconstruction était sans doute qui
méritera sans doute plus de temps mais
là où c'est inexcusable c'est évidemment
porte sur sur les sur les injures sur
les disputes et là il faut vraiment
prendre de la maturité je suis d'accord
avec ceux et celles qui ont dit je pense
à la ministre des sports valérie
fourneyron ou à d'autres qui ont dit
qu'il faudrait sans doute procéder à
l'exclusion des joueurs quel que soit
par ailleurs leur qualité des joueurs
qui se comportait mal je ne respectais
pas une certaine déontologie je suis
aussi pour cette démarche est en tout
cas ceux celles qui ont proposé que l'on
donne pas les 140 mille euros de primes
aux joueurs en d'éleveurs vole dit oui
j'ai dit randa
une vache ou en partenariat avec orange
et leur application qui s'appelle tivi
tchèque
les internautes peuvent vous poser des
questions il ya beaucoup de questions
autour de la gestion de la crise du
virus h1n1
je vous en cite une notamment celle de
jimmy le marchand kingi comment vous
expliquer la mise sur le marché du
vaccin en moins de huit mois alors que
les effets secondaires de ce vaccin ne
sont vu qu'au bout de plusieurs années
oui parce que nous faisons cela tous les
ans il y a en quelque sorte des
maquettes de vaccins qui sont
parfaitement des supports de vaccins qui
sont parfaitement identifiés et
évidemment comme le virus mute chaque
année ou tous les deux ans il ne m'est
pas où tous les trois ans on met la
souche incriminée dans en quelque sorte
le support le support du vaccin mais le
vaccin lui est tout à fait étudier
évidemment on met chaque année la souche
la souche qui est qui est concerné on va
pas protéger les gens fait qu'une souche
qui n'est pas à l'origine de la grippe
mais j'ai sont pas ce sont des sujets
techniques qui peuvent ne pas apparaître
clairement un public qui voit par
ailleurs que des produits sont testés
pendant des années ils sont
effectivement pendant testé pendant des
années est ce que cette gestion de cette
crise du virus reste votre échec de
communication ce qui est important c'est
de dire que c'est un succès dans dans
l'évaluation de ce qu'il faut faire et
je dois dire que tout bien considéré je
referais exactement la même chose quand
on ne connaît pas un danger on prend la
précaution maximum ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est le b à ba
le b à ba de la santé publique alors
c'est vrai qu'on a été l'objet
d'attaqués à la fois de l'opposition qui
s'en est saisie après avoir dit bien
entendu qu'on n'en faisait pas assez
je pense non déclaration monsieur le
guen qui disait le gouvernement ne prend
pas la mesure
urbaine qui dément et n'a pas été nommé
ministre de la santé ça dure et ça je
peux pas me réjouir mais je pense que
madame marisol touraine s'en est méfié
je pense qu'elle a sans doute eu raison
n'en a pas voulu comme ministre délégué
à la santé
voilà et puis les verts trouvaient que
je devais acheter des combinaisons des
scaphandres de protection et des
lunettes de piscine pour protéger les
personnes delà du virus h1 et n'a
heureusement qu'on a passionné c'est
quoi cet actif qu'un prototype ça fait
rire un peu ça fait rire ont ils envoyé
d'ailleurs spéciale de carla bruni c'est
ça je crois que c'est fred vargas ou ne
donnait pas son nom mais qui vous a
proposé une combinaison se protéger du
virus
on va jeter si vous voulez bien là
dessus le voit à voile pudique donc très
bien voilà il faudra refaire là il
faudra refaire la même chose on va
refaire les mêmes choses
il ya une chose qui va nous aider c'est
que depuis ont été créés les agences
régionales de santé et que à l'évidence
nous n'avions alors que l'organisation
chez préfectoral et que les préfets ne
sont pas outillés pour gérer une grande
crise sanitaire
la veille et la sécurité sanitaire
seront de la responsabilité des agences
régionales de santé donc nous allons
progresser on parler de votre avenir
tout à l'heure il paraît que vous allez
devenir chroniqueuse télé c'est vrai que
j'ai certains projets professionnels
rien n'est fait
je n'ai jamais eu de proposition je vais
peut-être venir vous faire concurrence
rien n'est fait rien n'est fait à
conclure en dit long sur la demande de
roselyne bachelot peut-être sur les
antennes de direct 8 à la rentrée ou
d'autres ou d'autres encore la merci des
sièges dans vos nouveau virage
professionnel
madame bachelot comme si vous restez
très ancré dans la politique on l'a
compris merci bonsoir à tous
il y à 50 ans le 5 juillet 1962
l'algérie devenait indépendante
c'était un instant de bonheur de voir la
joie de revoir le déferlement
d'enthousiasmé
c'est un axe entre les leaders de la
guerre raconte à benjamin stora et jean
michel meurice
comment leur vie a basculé nous
imaginions que nous allons tous faire
j'ai mal dans la mare c'était la lutte
pour le pouvoir tu avais commencé
algérie l'indépendance aux deux visages
samedi à 22h sur public sénat se
renseigner sur les programmes
voir ou revoir les émissions suivre le
fil d'information politique et
parlementaire pour vivre la politique en
temps réel connectez vous et réagissez
sur publicsenat.fr
nicolas canteloup un ancien des guignols
campe lui aussi il y est toujours enfin
pu beaucoup on a cru comprendre
ponctuellement quand lui aussi un
président qui parle d'autre chose
quand on interroge exemple au lendemain
de la mort de kadhafi et de la naissance
de la petite giulia alors l'actualité
bien sûr c'est la mort de kadhafi met ce
sarkozy on a envie de vous entendre sur
ce sujet vous savez je crois que c'est
mais ce n'est pas le sujet qui passionne
les français voulaient mais non mais qui
mieux
qui mieux que moi que quiconque c'est ce
qui intéresse les français c'est quoi le
sujet qui passionne les français pas
kadhafi c'est par les primaires
socialistes ce qui passerait français
les mulhousiens et quoi c'est ce
scandale ce scandale des biberons au
bisphénol
ça vous intéresse parce que vous êtes
papa depuis 24 heures le cercle ar 2
jeux secrets mais aujourd'hui on donne à
nos bébés des biberons radioactifs et
tout le monde s'en fout c'est sa
léthargie tant qu'attaquant divin pas
amenons nous enfants patauger dans la
piscine de fukushima dernière faisant
sécher nos bébés dans un micro-ondes
linthal crawler les fakes à l'anthrax
aussi pas content je soulève ce parce
que j'ai d'autres priorités mondiales
mois il faut bien finir d'installer la
démocratie en libye où j'ai à faire
chauffer les biberons du pied la brune
aux questions vous disiez aujourd'hui m2
l'éditorialisation chez les humoristes
alors la question c'est ce que justement
quand tout est dans le même registre que
les guignols aujourd'hui ou ou pas il a
biberonné donc de toutes façons il a été
il a fait les voix des guignols il est
fait encore ponctuellement bon ni
probablement ce qui est très difficile
pour un caricaturiste de carrick eric
caricaturer une caricature sarkozy porte
en lui sa propre caricature mais je suis
plus aux guignols et je suis très
content de ne pas avoir à le traiter
parce que je ne saurais pas comment
faire mais oui c'est très difficile il
est déjà une caricature il est déjà ils
se il se passe il se passe là il est
transparent ce type là quand il veut
faire président en disant je veux
prendre de la hauteur ça se voit et là
nous se voit et alors du coup et le
caricaturant quoi en caricaturant la
caricature ils font de la périphérie qui
tourne autour du personnage lui n'entre
pas dans le personnage jessains
numérique atur c'est sur ses efforts ses
tentatives sans rentrer à l'intérieur
c'est ça mon travail en périphérie sur
des blogs
je trouve que les humoristes pardon
brice met à jour des des problèmes et
des questions que les journalistes ne
soulève pas toujours utiles ce mardi a
ajouté l'ars exemple la caisse qu'est ce
qu'on voit un personnage narcissique et
manipulateur ce qu'on nous a montré l'un
de nicolas sarkozy mais du tout du même
registre que jacques chirac jacques
chirac finalement on nous dit c'est
quelqu'un qui ment alors ça peut
déplaire puisque à chaque fois c'est la
question de la sincérité
c'est quelqu'un qui ment mais finalement
il affiche ses mensonges et là il ya
toujours cette fonction je crois de
dévoilement mais on nous dit finalement
nicolas sarkozy c'est quelqu'un d'assez
narcissique qui nous dit c'est grâce à
moi la libye etc etc
et puis le manipulateur parce que vous
l'avez dit vous-même il ne répond pas à
la question où il répond à la question
en reprenant quelque chose en le
déplaçant et l exagérer le coût des
biberons par exemple alors il va falloir
quand même du talent que sur les effets
des enfants etc etc
il amplifie donc ça met en scène quelque
chose qui est beaucoup moins sympathique
je pense pour nicolas sarkozy que pour
ajaccio s'est finalement rendu à
l'intérieur du personnel en trois mois
je crois que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
rentré j'ai l'impression à l'intérieur
ou pas ses passions des oasis quelque
chose qu'on associe à ses personnages
c'est vrai que françois hollande était
connu effectivement pour son humour ses
blagues et alors ce qui a été ce qu'on a
pu relever c'est qu'au soir de sa
victoire est bien ou pas les blagues
revenaient même lorsqu'il parlait de
nicolas sarkozy alors certes il était
passé à ses supporters donc un peu en
famille mais ce discours était
retransmis sur toutes les télés on
regarde elle sera âpre cette campagne
parce que nous avons une droite et une
extrême droite
nous avons fini par les oublier temps
nous étions finalement les seuls à
couvrir l'espace médiatique au point
qu'il va falloir se mettre maintenant à
la diète
moi j'avais commencé depuis longtemps
vous me direz mais enfin sur un autre
terrain mais il va falloir se mettre à
la diète médiatique parce que d'abord il
va falloir reprendre nos forces
et puis ensuite parce que c'est le débat
démocratique qui va trouver sa place et
la droite j'ai compris avait déjà
anticipé puisque nous allons avoir le
président de la république qui va
s'exprimer dans quelques jours nous
l'entendons moi je mène j'ai même
plaisir à l'entendre tant il me paraît
avoir disparu de la circulation
alors il blake sur lui d'être sur son
régime
il est très applaudie et alors ça nous a
rappelé quand même le françois hollande
de 2007 qui à l'époque aussi attaqué
nicolas sarkozy toujours sur le mode de
l'humour alors on va comparer y at il
des points communs des différences on
regarde un extrait et là on a presque
l'impression d'un one man show depuis il
faut s'inscrire rien il ya une confiance
j'ai changé et la droite et les
complexés aujourd'hui je
le président semble s je parle à tout le
monde
j'avais tant les chantiers